you wrote In the book that your father
had a big influence on your life what
lessons have you learned about life for
your father when you ask that question
you
know I remember Cato when I was with him
up been cat all those years he used to
say to me Teddy you you learned through
osmosis I believe this true to that if I
know what osmosis is
and and I but it sounds good yeah yeah
but I learned through osmosis with my
father he he wasn't a big talker he was
you know he was a doer and I when you're
around someone who lives a certain kind
of life and does certain
things uh it penetrates he was a doctor
he was I I'm going to sound like an
idiot right now because I'm being a son
uh but he was the greatest diagonistic
doctor yeah I mean if I say I ever knew
what's that mean yeah you know what I
mean are you a doctor you know you know
what I mean like what does that mean but
other people have told me this yeah like
just legendary stories he would do house
calls and he help people and like you
said a lot of people have spoken about
the impact he's had on their life he
built two hospitals and he he built a
hospital before the verado bridge in New
York uh connecting Brooklyn to statown
and he he built it so people could get
proper hospital care they couldn't
afford it period and um everybody looked
at him as uh eccentric yeah nice yeah
because because he he would literally
sneak patience not sneak him in he was
Dr hatas he could do what he wanted to a
certain extent but he would bring
patience in without administering
putting through Administration so there
was no charge because you know they they
didn't have anything they were Street
people they were I I remember being my
only way to be with my father was to go
on house calls yeah or to go to the
office there's no you know and so I went
on house calls well and he did house
calls by the way till he was 80 and and
$3 I mean it was better than like
McDonald's you know what I mean I mean
the deal you $3 and you got medicine you
got
everything and but he used to right
around the holidays there was just
certain things that I didn't understand
but I understood later where we would
just drive certain areas and he just
over sudden open his door he would pick
up these H and you know I'm I'm 10 years
old yeah you know move over move over
you know M and it's just you him and a
homeless guy a couple yeah a couple yeah
whatever you can fit in three four you
know whatever it was that's a big heart
and then he took him to the hospital
dropped them so you know I would ask
questions after it was all over with I'd
say that they're sick he goes well not
not in a way well you put them in the
hospital mhm
so he said yeah and he tried to explain
things to me you know he would try he
didn't talk much unless you asked him
something yeah that kind of works and
you know don't talk let someone ask you
something yeah and he he he explained to
me that he said um I said well why you
put them in the hospital then I you know
and of course the sicknesss was the
alcoholics but um why why you put him
he's it wasn't an alcohol rehab you know
so why you put him and it wasn't for the
purpose was to dry out MH he wasn't
trying to cure them yeah let's put that
for before we we anointed him for saood
you know Like by Teddy Atlas so I was
like we we finally get to the point why
you put him in there yeah well because
it's the
holidays all right why you put them in
there well the holidays you know are
good for certain people and bad for
others and um and it was always before
the holidays it was before Christmas
before whatever and and um New Year's
whatever and so I said
why and he said
because they remind people certain
people of what they don't
have that you other people are enjoy the
holidays because of what they have
family you know whatever and it reminds
them their mind is that that's pretty
profound yeah and and
then I I don't know remember because he
didn't use the word suicide but I I got
it like he he basically I forget how he
said it but like I just got it I don't
know how I got Osmos I don't know but I
just got it like so they don't hurt
themselves that that's what came across
way I don't think he ever articulated
that ever verbalized that but yeah they
don't hurt themselves so and well how
how does that work well just basically
they're going to be around people
they're not going to be alone they're
gonna be around people they're going to
get fed they're gonna be warm right and
it's going to be for three days two
three days whatever and it's basically
it's it's a bridge so and the the funny
thing as a 10-year-old I I wanted
to I want to be connected to him so I I
I enlisted myself in a job when when
when he used to drop them off he he
would take them get them in right and
um and then the thing that I know again
he didn't say nothing but I you notice
things and if you care enough you don't
you don't notice nothing if you don't
care but if you care if it's important
you notice and this guy was important to
me I just was I didn't know what a hero
was no clue I love Mickey Mano I love
Willie Maye I love I I love Muhammad Ali
I I I never ever connected in my mind as
Heroes never my
father I I didn't connect it that way
but he looking back now looking back he
he was my first connection to a hero the
two of you ever talk about how much you
love each
other one one thing that was uh not
allowed the the greatest memory I have
my father shown me love was we were down
in Florida at an airport and and um we
were I was born in Miami don't ask me I
was passing through and the rest my
family is born in New York St now and so
I was supposed to go back with him right
and I wanted to stay with my mother for
whatever reason and so he you know he of
course conceited to it and he's he's
okay you know whatever and very quiet
very and this is a man who never showed
emotion to anyone I mean for the most
you know really all of a
sudden he just turned kiss me on the
forehead and left and I was I was
like that's different yeah you still
remember that yeah like that's weird you
lost them 30 years ago how how did that
change
you it made me realize that some of the
deals I used to make for god um more
realistic when I was a kid I used to
make deals with God let me die before my
father
and then you know you get older and you
have kids you're
blessed why did you make that deal you
know what I mean
like thank you for not taking me up on
it yeah thanks
yeah you know H yeah you miss him I miss
him in moments when I'd like to know
what to
do and um
you know I I remember when I would
driving with one of house calls he
didn't listen to
music he was a guy he read books to his
when he got older he read books to uh
blood vessel was broken his eyes he only
read non-fiction books science he loves
science um Wars um generals I mean I
cheated on a couple uh book reports
because of him because I didn't do the
reading of the book theight before I had
a freaking uh book report to put in that
I got a book report to do on H St the
war of Stalingrad yeah really the war of
Stalingrad and who the freak could tell
you where you get an A I got an A yeah
he I just wrote what he told me told me
generals he told me times he told me
strategy he told me about the winter
that came and destroyed the Germans and
and and the Soviets were tough them and
the Soviets tougher than the Germans and
you know the Germans picked on the wrong
opponent yeah I was already in the
boxing business yeah I didn't even know
it I didn't even know it yeah
matchmaking very important yeah they
they they mismatched they did they made
a mistake with the picking the opponent
and so when we would be driving in the
car my father would be in a
trance and Dad he wasn't ignoring me MH
at all he was just with his thoughts M
he was he was wherever he wasn't even
here in the radio no
more I always wonder where he was I did
so I asked him one day and just so we're
driving I said I want to know so I said
dad what do you think when you're
basically in this place that I know
you're somewhere yeah what what do you
what do you where are you what are you
seeing I actually said what do you
see and he said to me I see what could
be I see what could be and I'm like
oh